so we want to go to another story um
that's been brewing tonight so for weeks
as you know the january 6th committee
has been holding hearings they've been
widely covered on the other channels we
haven't seen the news value in them but
there is a bit of news to emerge from
that story and we want to get to it now
so the new york times has written
hundreds and hundreds of articles about
january 6th since it happened describing
it as a riot insurrection
as part of its coverage last summer the
times published a video documentary in
which the times reported that one man
was actually caught on camera planning
an insurrection encouraging a breach of
the capital complex that man's name is
ray apps now the new york times noted
that epps was videotaped on both january
5th and january 6th urging protesters to
storm the capital here it is we need to
go in
to the capitol
let's go
i'm going to put it out there i'm
probably going to go to jail
tomorrow
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
now in a lot of ways that's the
strangest video to emerge from january
6. we played it several times in this
show quote we need to go into the
capital into the capitol reyes tells the
crowd he says it repeatedly he's so
emphatic about it encouraging other
people to commit a crime that the crowd
around him decides he must be a federal
agent they began chanting as you just
heard fed fed so shortly after that
video surfaced the fbi placed ray epps
on a list of people wanted for
questioning they released it to the
public and you can understand why they
did that
according to the justice department what
ray epps did on that video is a federal
crime in fact the bite administration
has charged several people with
seditious conspiracy for doing precisely
what you just saw ray epps do urging
others to enter the capital complex on
january 6. here for example is a quote
from a doj press release it describes
the federal case against five members of
the so-called proud boys the group
you're supposed to be terrified of quote
on january 6 2021 the defendants
directed mobilized and led members of
the crowd onto the capitol grounds and
into the capital end quote again that's
what you just saw ray epps tried to do
but here's the difference others who
have done that are in prison or facing
long terms in prison but no charges have
ever been filed against ray epps despite
the fact there's no question did it
because once more it's on tape
that's very strange it just is
and we don't care how people call us
names for pointing that out it is
strange and we'd like an answer to what
the heck is going on now we've asked rey
apps on this show repeatedly to explain
why he thinks he has escaped prosecution
and we'll ask him once again tonight and
we will keep asking because we think it
is a very obvious and important question
that gets to the heart of what is this
exactly
but it's amazing how little democrats
want to hear about this again nancy
pelosi and liz cheney spent the last
year staging an investigation at great
expense and then a series of public show
trials arresting people in their homes
supposedly designed to discover how and
why january 6th happened
but they remain curiously uninterested
in the epps case
we've got what seems like an actual
insurrectionist on tape but they don't
want to talk about it and they
definitely don't want you to talk about
it or ask any questions
as if to prove that point the new york
times just ran a piece explaining that
when you ask questions about reyes you
are committing a moral crime maybe even
helping putin the piece was entitled
it's just been hell
life as the victim of a january 6
conspiracy theory
oh so ray apps the guy telling people to
breach the capital is now in the words
of the new york times a victim a victim
of your unrestrained curiosity
now this piece was written by a reporter
who has spent years shilling openly for
the intelligence agency
may give you some sense of where the
story line comes from like the agencies
themselves the new york times piece was
highly deceptive
for example the new york times says that
epps was quote taped urging people to go
to the capitol
oh but that's not what the tape shows
reps was doing something very different
reps was urging people to go into the
capital not to the capitol and there's a
big difference legally
one is a crime according to the doj and
the other is not a crime
and that's not all reps did
epps also told people what they should
do once they got inside the capital and
that's on video too this is just minutes
before the first breach of the building
that day watch
one more thing yeah if we go up there
no when we go in are we going to get
arrested
you don't need to get shot
when you go and leave this here what
does that mean
well for some reason the new york times
reporter didn't ask gray epps what he
meant by that now the reporter spent a
day talking to epps it was a day-long
conversation according to the story but
that question never came up
no meaningful question came up
it's all very strange the new york times
is mounting a propaganda campaign on
behalf of a self-described trump voter
insurrectionist
now this is the same paper that cheered
ashley babbitt's death
but this same paper is weeping for ray
epps because people have been mean to
him online
it's almost like they're trying to cover
something up
now buried near the end of the new york
times piece there's a hint we find this
line quote mr epps also said he
regretted sending a text to his nephew
well after the violence had erupted in
which he discussed how he helped
orchestrate the movements of people who
were leaving mr trump's speech near the
white house by pointing them in the
direction of the capital
really
what was in that text
we never heard of that before and it
kind of makes you think the entire new
york times piece was written to drop
that little bomblet at the end in the
least damaging way and we've never seen
that text message before what exactly
did ray epp say to his nephew have
prosecutors reviewed that text the new
york times doesn't tell us nor does the
new york times tell us whether ray epps
has had any contact with any federal
agencies in the period before january 6.
that's the core question
but they didn't ask it
why is that seems like a major omission
but don't ask more questions come into
the new york times otherwise rey epps
may be killed by mexican drug cartels
mexican drug cartels what do they have
to do with this we're not sure but
according to the paper there are people
who have heard quote some cartel members
talking about killing mr epps
right because the drug cartels are
committed trump voters and they feel
betrayed by rey apps maybe they're
queuing on people too
this is highly strange and if you're
going to spend more than a year looking
into january 6th and you ignore this
then it's more than strange
it's an indictment of your motives
darren beatty is one of the reasons this
piece was first written he's
the editor of revolver news which
published the first stories about ray
epps obviously the new york times is
very worried about his reporting we're
happy to have him join us tonight daryn
thanks so much for coming on
what do you make of this
well it's pretty remarkable i mean just
let's take all of this in the one person
caught repeatedly urging people into the
capital as early as january 5th is the
one person of all of the january 6 riot
participants that the new york times
just happens to write this
ultra sympathetic puff piece for
uh it's it's quite remarkable and to
look at the piece itself as you uh
suggested in in your um in your intro
there are some real
glaring
omissions uh from a journalistic
standpoint to have access to the sky
number one in the entire piece there is
no blanket explicit denial on the on
part of epps to have been associated
with any intelligence group dhs jttf
military intelligence so forth just
reiterates his
very legal denial of being involved with
law law enforcement
number two the piece destr describes
epps as a trump supporter he just went
to went to dc to defend trump and to
attend the speech on a last minute uh
thing with his son to attend trump's
speech on election fraud the only thing
is epps didn't attend the speech
epps travels all the way from arizona to
d.c this big trump supporter and he
doesn't even attend the speech instead
he fixates on this bizarre mission to
get everyone to go in to the capitol and
by the way he just happens to be hanging
out
right by the initial breach point near
the peace monument on the west side of
the capitol before the proud boys even
get there
and thirdly
where did ray epps get this idea this
whole piece doesn't explore that
question at all here is the one person
calling for everyone to go in where did
you get that idea reyes did it occurred
to you out of nowhere did someone tell
you to do it this piece
shockingly does not explore that
question at all which is the paramount
question that's really the animating the
alleged animating focus of january 6
committee so this is so dirty rayapps's
behavior was so egregious that he was
one of the first 20 on the fbi most
wanted list he was featured as a star in
the new york times's own
documentary on january 6
and now
he's unarrested unindicted and he's the
only january 6 writer about whom adam
kinsader has nice things to say and the
new york times writing puff piece is
about he's the smallest
erection
well
and they go crazy when you ask simple
questions like what was the role of
federal law enforcement or the military
in this day and it's been our experience
that when they won't answer a question
and call you names for asking it maybe
there's something there i appreciate
your pulling this thread relentlessly
darren beatty thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight